you may remember a few years back Mahmud
akman NAD the president of Iran said he
wanted to come to ground zero and you
can bet that if there's a ground zero
mosque and akman NAD comes to speak to
the UN again you know he'll be there and
so we have Sahand kosbon who is an AR
Ian American human rights activist and
freedom fighter and he is an organizer
of the no to akman NAD committee which
sends protesters to stands for human
rights whenever the president of Iran
appears at the UN and so please welcome
Sahand
kosbon ladies and gentlemen today is a
solemn day for all of us a day to
remember and to pay tribute to the
thousands of innocent people who fell
victim to terrorism a day to pray for
the families of the victims who have
endured all these years and to wish them
more
strength on behalf of the Iranian
American Community from all across the
United States I would like to express my
condolences to you the families of the
victims of the 9911 tragedy Y and to
express our unity and our sharing of
your
pain as we think of our beloved victims
the terror Masters and the murderers are
at loose Mahmud Ahad NAD president of
the most repressive dictatorship and the
most active supporter of terrorism is
coming to New York City on September
23rd to shamefully address the United
Nations General
Assembly
who does this mad man represent the
execution of 120,000 political dissident
the brutal suppression of the uprising
by the millions in Iran murder of the
protesters including Nea a young woman
who became the symbol of the Iranian
people's struggle for freedom and the
victim of the evil that is out to
destroy love peace and
Liberty we the Iranian people have
pledged and made an oath to our Lord and
our fallen brothers and sisters that we
will cut the roots of terrorism and
Islamic fundamentalism whose
representative has the seat of
presidency in
Iran with a massive program to acquire
nuclear weapons the most dangerous
weapons will be in the hands of the most
dangerous man a recipe for a global
catastrophe the Crackdown of the
uprising of millions of Irani Ians over
the past year includes all sectors of
society many activists most of them
belonging to the main Iranian opposition
group The National Council of resistance
of Iran and the pmoi have been jailed
tortured hanged or sentenced to death
scores of them are on death row for
simply crying out for Freedom religious
minorities have been ruthlessly
suppressed a well-known Iranian Pastor
is currently facing execution as part of
a Crackdown on Christians there are
several other Christians in
jail his presence here is an insult to
humanity and particular to the people of
America and Iran who are together on
this a terror master and a holocaust Den
has no place at the UN we have to say no
to Ahmed NAD together we can eliminate
the Dark Cloud of terrorism by uniting
with the brave people in Iran in their
struggle for Freedom the Iranian
American communities are holding a major
rally in New York across from the United
Nations September 23rd starting at 11:00
a.m. the rally is the voice of all our
loved ones who have lost their lives to
terrorism please stand with the Iranians
and and their cry for freedom and human
rights against the terror Masters and
The
Butchers we ask our Lord to give us
strength endurance and peace in our day
of Sorrow we believe that peace will be
achieved we believe that love will
prevail but only when we stand together
we must stand together please help be
the voice of the voiceless in Iran let's
plant the seed of Peace together let's
establish a harmonious world and leave a
future for our children on behalf of the
not to am Nar committee and the Iranian
American Community I thank you for this
opportunity and we are honor to have
honored you and to have shared your pain
thank
you